the Libertarians and the Communists I  think ultimately share the same view of  anthropology ultimately they believe  that men are fundamentally individuals  born primarily in in as much as we have  a political life with rights and  entitlements and the commies say we're  all individuals and then they Bunch us  all up together and they're sort of a  hideous Collective and the Libertarians  just don't get to that next stage but  both of them reject the reality of man  is not nearly an individual but is a  social being as a political animal born  into a family in time and space into a  community into a nation with I think  primarily duties and obligations and  traditions and he has rights and things  too but that's not the primary fact of  his political nature